قراءه في كل هذه التطورات قراءه عسكريه مع
ضيفنا من اسطنبول الخبير العسكري
والاستراتيجي العقيد الركن هاتم كريم
الفلاحي اهلا بك عقيد الفلاحي من واقع
خبراتك في التحليل
العسكري ومن قراءتك القريبه لمجريات
الامور في غزه ما طبيعه هذه المعارك
البريه التي تجري الان في شمال قطاع غزه
وجنوبه
نعم مساء الخير لكم ومشاهدي قناه الجزيره
نعم لا شك بان الحرب الان بدات تحتدم بشكل
كبير جدا في هذه المرحله التي تعتبر هي
مرحله حاسمه وعنيفه وقاسيه على الطرفين
خصوصا وان قوات الاحتلال الصهيوني تحاول
تعزيز قطعاتها المتواجده المتوغلة
هذه القضيه نقول بانه من يراقب الساحه
يعني يجد بان هناك تغييرات طرات على
العمليه العسكريه خلال هذه الفتره وهو ان
الاحتلال بدا يستخدم الطائرات المروحيه
طائرات الاباتشي بكثره خلال الايام
الاخيره هذه الطائره فيها قدره تسليح
عاليه وقادره على المناوره بشكل كبير جدا
وهي تعمل في مختلف الظروف الجويه وقادره
على كشف الاهداف الثابته والمتحركه فيها
ثلاثه منظومات رؤيه احدها ليليه فيها 16
صاروخ هيل فاير فيها مدفع رشاش 30 ملم
وفيها اكثر من اطلا 1200 اطلاقه تستطيع
رمي ما يقارب 625 طلقه في الدقيقه لديها
امكانيات قتاليه كبيره جدا قادره على
الاشتباك القريب والبعيد ويمكن ان تستخدم
بالعمق جرى تفعيل هذه الطائره خلال هذه
الفتره لذلك نرى بانه يستخدمها بشكل كثيف
الان في المنطقه الشماليه والظاهر بان
هناك اهداف بدات تظهر ويحاولون استدعاء
الطائرات السمتيه اما للتخلص من موقف
مرتبك تعبوي بالنسبه لقطعته المتقدمه في
الشمال او لغرض قصف اهداف معينه تم
تحديدها من قبل ضباط الرصد الاماميين في
هذه المنطقه ولكن بشكل عام نقول بان
المعارك في الشمال نعم ما الذي يختلف لدى
استخدام الجيش الاسرائيلي لهذه الطائرات
على الارض ما هي نتائج استخدامها كما
تبدو نعم هي القراءه هنا تاتي بان هذه
الطائرات لن تحسم هذه المعركه يعني في كل
الاحوال يجب ان تكون هناك قطعات تستطيع ان
تمسك هذه المناطق على الارض يعني استخدام
الطائرات والقصف التدميري منذ بدايه
العمليه العسكريه الى اليوم لم يحقق تقدم
كبير للجيش الصهيوني في هذه المناطق التي
تم تدميرها بجميع بناها التحتيه لذلك نقول
بان القضيه هي قضيه الاشتباك القريب مع
هذه القطعات الان المعارك التي تدور هي
معارك قتالات خاصه في مناطق مبنيه وهذه
القتالات تختلف بشكل كبير جدا عن القتال
في مناطق صحراويه او بين الجيوش النظاميه
لذلك نرى بان فاتوره الخسائر ترتفع
بالنسبه للجيش الصهيوني كلما حاول التوغل
في هذه المناطق يضاف الى ذلك بان استخدام
الاعداد الكبيره للجيش عرض هذا هذه القوات
الى خسائر كبيره لذلك نرى بان بان القضيه
الان في الشمال او في الوسط او في الجنوب
المعارك تحتدم بشكل كبير ولكن هناك خطه
دفاعيه هي حقيقه نستطيع ان نقول انها
منسقه بشكل جيد وهي تقوم باستهداف القوات
المتقدمه حسب محاور التقدم وحسب طبيعه
الارض والموقف التعبوي وهذا ما يجهله لحد
هذه اللحظه الكيان الصهيوني حقي حقيقه
الجيش المتقدم لديه اخطاء كبيره لان يجب
ان يكون هناك تقيييم للاخطاء وتصحيح
للاخطاء بما يتلا مع المعطى الذي يعطيه
الواقع والا ستكون الخسائر اكبر بكثير مما
سبق في الفتره الماضيه من نتائج الخطه
الدفاعيه كما وصفتها بالمناسب ق بشكل جيد
للمقاومه ما ذكره بيان كتائب القسام قبل
قليل وما استطاعت او ما استطاع عناصر
كتائب القسام انجازه على الارض استهداف
لجرافات
صهيونيه من نوع الدي ت بقذيفه الياسين 105
في شمال مخيم البريج واسقاط طائره استطلاع
من طراز سكايلارك اثنين كانت بمهمه
استخباراتيه للعدو في بيت حانون شمالي
قطاع غزه هذا ما ورد في بيان كتائب القسام
كيف نقراه
طبيعه الطائره التي اسقطت
والجرافك
ايضا نعم في هذه القراءه نقول بانه من
يحاول ان يشكك بقدرات المقاومه فهو واهم
وهو لا يقرا الموقف بشكل صحيح ولا يقرا
ساحه المعركه بشكل صحيح والدليل على هذا
عندما يتم اطلاق اطلاق صواريخ باتجاه
مناطق غلاف غزه اذا هم يقومون بقصف
التجمعات او التحشد التي يمكن ان تستخ ت
خدم في معركه في مرحله لاحقه من المعركه
وبالتالي هم يتم قصف هذه بالصواريخ التي
تصل الى هذه المناطق عندما يتم اسقاط
طائره استطلاع هذا يعني بان هناك الان
بدات المقاومه تفرز قسم من الاسلحه
لمواجهه الطائرات السمتيه او المروحيه
طائرات الاباتشي بالاضافه الى الطائرات
الاستطلاع التي يتم استخدامها من قبل
الجيش في هذه المنطقه بالامس كانت سرايا
القدس قامت بانزال احدى هذه الطائرات
اليوم القسام تسقط تسقط طائره مسيره اذا
هذا انجاز بالنسبه للمقاومه بان هناك
ترتيب وهناك خططه لمعالجه جميع التهديدات
التي يمكن ان تشكل خطر على المقاومه يضاف
الى ذلك بان تدمير هذه الجرافه يعطي دلاله
واضحه على ان هناك خطه منسقه ومعلومات
دقيقه عن محاور التقدم وهناك استخدام جيد
للاسلحه المتوفره لدى فصائل المقاومه لان
هذه الجرافه هي التي تقوم بفتح الطرق لغرض
تقدم القطعات الاليه والمدرعه فعندما ما
يتم استهداف هذه الجرافه بمعنى وقف محور
التقدم من هذا المكان اذا هم يقومون
باصطياد الاهداف حسب اهميتها وحسب حسب
قدرتهم على اصطياد هذه الاهداف لذلك نقول
بان الخطط يمكن ان تتغير كليا ويمكن ان
تتغير جزئيا حسب طبيعه المعركه وحسب
الامكانيات والقدرات وحسب الاهداف
المرسومه ضمن الخطه التعبويه خطه الجيش
الاسرائيلي هل يبدو انها تتغير مع هذه
التطورات مع هذه الخسائر اليوميه في صفوف
الجنود والضباط الاسرائيليين ما يجري في
خان يونس مثلا اضافه اللواء السابع
والتحاقه بالمعارك هناك هل هو دلاله خطه
جديده ام ماذا عقيد
الفلاح نعم لا شك هم في هذه في هذه الفتره
قالوا بانهم سيقومون بتغيير وتطوير الخطط
الموجوده لديهم وهم يحاولون ان يزجون
قطعات جديده في هذه المعركه فالل واء الذي
تكلموا عليه باتجاه خان يونس هو اللواء
السابع هذا اللواء مدرع يعني اذا ما تم
استخدامه في هذه المنطقه ولكن عندما نتكلم
عن الخطط ونتكلم عن التغيير نقول بانها
يجب ان تحاكي الواقع ولكن من يرى الواقع
يجد بان المقاومه وضعت الجيش الصهيوني في
خيارات احلاها مر بالنسبه اليه اذا ما
استمر بهذه العمليه فهناك عمليه فاتوره
خسائر كبيره جدا وهناك تكلفه باهضه يدفعها
الجيش الصهيوني نتيجه الخسائر التي يمنى
بها في ساحه المعركه لاسباب كثيره منها
قله خبره الجيش في القتال في المناطق
المبنيه وعدم قدرته على توظيف المعلومات
والقدرات العسكريه بشكل صحيح بالاضافه الى
ان الخطط لم تكن بالمستوى المطلوب الذي
يمكنه من انجاز شيء على الارض يضاف الى
ذلك بان عدم قدرته على مواجهه الانفاق
وعدم قدرته على وضع حد لفصائل المقاومه
باستخدامها الصحيح للارض ولاس هذا سبب اخر
يضاف الى فشل الجيش الاسرائيلي في تحقيق
اي انجاز على الارض لذلك الاسباب كثيره
ونقول بشكل كبير بانه اذا ما استمرت
القطعات بالتدفق الى داخل منطقه غزه فست
تتعرض الى خسائر اكبر بكثير مما تعرضت
اليه في الفتره الماضيه شكرا جزيلا لك
الخبير العسكري والاستراتيجي العقيد الركن
حاتم كريم الفلاحي كنت معنا من
اسطنبول